lightning wrong question ready favorite
actor go die I don't know nobody maybe
Michael key
happy November everybody this is top
five and today we're going back to the
roots of the show with an actor who's
been heavily requested from the very
beginning Tim Curry Michael key Robert
DeNiro Michael key John Cena Tommy
what's up Michael key Polly sure what
why are you always doing that Michael
Keaton has been a Hollywood legend for
decades his signature personality and
high energy made him popular in the
1980s since then he's grown to be a very
well rounded actor and from Batman to
Birdman his dramatic range is just as
well-known as his comedic chops age has
not slowed him down either as many
believe his best work has come in the
last decade this guy isn't just a
comic-book movie icon his skills have
only gotten better as he's gracefully
aged and at 67 Keaton has continued to
choose projects that challenge us while
maintaining his immense pop culture
status with all these fantastic roles to
choose from it's not easy to just pick a
handful but we're here to give you the
best and that's what you'll get these
are the top five best Michael Keaton
performances number five
Dogberry and much ado about nothing this
is quite possibly Keaton's best purely
comedic performance hero the young
daughter of the Machine Ian governor and
Claudio and Arakanese count are to be
Wed however the night before their
wedding an elaborate ruse leads Claudio
and his prince Don Pedro to believe that
hero has been unfaithful this was set up
by Don Pedro's jealous half-brother Don
John confusion hurt feelings and painful
accusations then ensue as you can tell
from the movie's description Dogberry
isn't a huge character in the story he
serves the narrative as comedic relief
in a role that many other actors may
have portrayed his annoying but Keaton
ends up completely stealing the show
every scene he's in you can't take your
eyes off of him it's like someone
completely let him off the leash and
it's the best thing ever remember are
you a nurse not really a nurse
he's insane delusional and hysterical
all at the same time also always at a
ten his energy is through the roof in
every shot even when he's not talking
Keaton's comedic timing and much ado
about nothing is nothing short of
perfect like a most thankful and
Reverend youth and I praise God for this
for thy pains
he's so off-the-wall that it makes you
want to see more of him
so you cherish every scene he's in as a
gift I wish we could show more clips
because he's brilliant in all of them
but here's one more for the road what is
your name friend
bacio write down vulture
number four Beetlejuice in beetlejuice
Adam and Barbara Maitland have recently
died in a car accident after realizing
they're dead they are stuck haunting
their home and are not able to leave
soon the Dietz family moves in and
completely changes the house the only
one who can see the Maitland's is Lydia
a strange and unusual teenager
eventually Barbara and Adam get
desperate and summon Beetlejuice the
dangerous bio-exorcist to scare the
deetzes out of their home
this results in unpredictable and unsafe
situations for both the Maitland's and
the deetzes It's Showtime
this might just be Michael Keaton's most
well-known role like and much ado about
nothing his comedic personality and
mile-a-minute energy shine through but
this time the focus is more on him in
this twisted yet somehow delightful
early Tim Burton film we even shop in
the same store hey hermano if you're
familiar with Keaton's career at all
you're most likely familiar with
Beetlejuice it was such a unique
character and performance his quick
thinking and utterly entertaining
one-liners where sometimes improvised
onset ah well I attend to truly I I'm
graduated Harvard Business School I
travel quite extensively I lived through
the Black Plague and I had a pretty good
time during
I've seen yetzer cysts about 167 times
kids get funnier every single time I see
it while Betelgeuse is usually hilarious
there's a darker side to him that Keaton
shows off well he can be pretty creepy
in a depraved kind of way Betelgeuse the
movie balances it's weird yet endearing
tone flawlessly something we may have to
explore much deeper in a future episode
Betelgeuse the character is just about
as signature performance Michael Keaton
has ever given number three
Ray Kroc in the founder you guys are we
get some McDonald's them yeah no thanks
not a fan of the Golden Arches huh well
this movie won't make you feel any
better the founder is the true story of
Ray Kroc a down-on-his-luck yet
determined salesman and how he met the
McDonald brothers in the 1950s the
multi-billion dollar industry that is
today's McDonald's started with crocks
vision of a national franchise
juggernaut that he essentially stole
from the brothers Mac and Dick MacDonald
innovated how fast their kitchen ran
while still producing quality food as
crock went into business with them to
expand the restaurant all over the
country ambition ruthless business
practices and relentless persistence
encompass this American success story
this performance really shows off
Keaton's range
Ray Kroc is portrayed as a fully
realized character from sympathetic and
even likable to completely hated by the
end of the movie the film has a very
unique vibe that blends humor with cruel
business moves and personal corruption
in the name of economic growth you know
contracts are like hearts they're made
to be program Keaton is amazing in the
role as he gets to play a variety of
emotions and motivations at the core of
this character is an unstoppable drive
for success no matter the cost
and that's no more apparent than in this
scene business is war it's dog eat dog
rat eat rat if my competitor were
drowning
I walk over and I put a hose right in
his mouth the founder is a great movie
with great performances not just from
Keaton the fact that it's the true story
of the biggest restaurant chain in
American history only adds to its
mystique if you haven't seen the film
consider it in an official top-five
recommendation number two
Batman / Bruce Wayne in Batman and
Batman Returns for many people this is
still the best Batman who has ever
graced the screen this is the part where
I'd break down the movies but I'm pretty
sure this clip will sum it up best for
you I'm Batman
I think he's pretty much equally as good
as the character in both his appearances
well maybe just a bit better in Batman
89 stop you all know why this
performance is on here I really
shouldn't have to say much but in short
Keaton's Batman saved the character from
it's campy phase and transitioned him
into the dark Avenger of the night we
all know him as now of course the
character was originally dark and the
comics well before Batman 89 had
returned the Caped Crusader to those
ways but this was the pop culture
phenomenon that cemented the Dark Knight
if for nothing else without Keaton's
Batman we never would have gotten Batman
the Animated Series that's reason enough
to praise his portrayal well I don't
think this version of the character is
perfect it's definitely distinct from
all the others we've seen so far this
Bruce Wayne is very unique he's out
there almost aloof and kind of crazy but
Michael Keaton crazy so it's awesome and
yet the pain of his loss and weight of
his self-imposed responsibilities is
intact here and it showed off in a few
key scenes it's just something I have to
do
why because nobody else can look I tried
to avoid all this but I can't this is
how it is I would have loved to have
seen where he could have taken the
character and he proposed to third film
even now I think he could plan Batman
Beyond movie anyone hell he could
probably still pull off being in the
cowl himself he may very well be the
Batman we deserve and the Batman we need
right now having to leave a few these
performances out of the top five was a
very difficult decision but cuts have to
be made somewhere so here are more of
mr. Keaton's best performances as
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one bet Michael Keaton
performance is brigand Thompson in
Birdman or the unexpected virtue of
ignorance this was the movie that marked
by some Keaton's comeback two big
starring roles and earned him an Oscar
nomination in the process riggan
Thompson was once a box-office sensation
as the superhero Birdman now years later
he's trying to shed the stigma of being
a washed-up movie star by directing and
starring in a major Broadway production
it's a risky move and with pressure
mounting things are going wrong at every
turn and on top of that an unstable
relationship his ex-wife and daughter
hanging around and a voice in his head
that gets louder with every setback and
you have a man on the verge of a mental
breakdown I almost can't put into words
how absolutely incredible Michael Keaton
is in this movie he was born to play
this character it was faked
the script was not written with him in
mind but his real life story marrying
Riggins in some ways made for the
perfect backdrop knowing who he is going
in makes the movie and performance even
better movie itself is so interesting
and different and not just because it's
portrayed to be in mostly one continuous
shot I could spend an hour talking about
Birdman and the little intricacies that
make it so good just as I can spend an
hour talking about Keaton's performance
specifically guys if you haven't seen
this movie you need to go out and watch
it nothing I can say will accurately
describe the experience of seeing it we
watch as Keaton runs through every
emotion in the spectrum we laugh with
him we cry with him we ponder with him
we get frustrated with them it's so raw
and riggan is such a vulnerable
character I have many favorite moments
in the film from funny popularity is
bloody little cousin of Christine
okay I don't know what the fuck nothing
so too maddening we're not disappearing
to set - missed a moment really
don't I have a I should we just been
there the two of you you know just it's
all there and more Birdman blows
everything else out of the water
Michael Keaton is a powerhouse in this
performance and that's not even the
latest in a string of great films since
he's been back on top
this guy continues to get better into
his late 60s and it was an honor getting
to watch his best performances from past
to present on my personal channel this
week I have a discussion about something
that I've been thinking about for years
we all know Keaton was a great bet but
what his natural personality have been a
better fit for the Joker join me over at
youtube.com slash awesome Walter and
let's get this conversation started we
want to hear what you guys think with
your favorite Michael Keaton performance
what do you want to see us cover next on
the show leave a comment and let us know
to keep in touch - you could like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
you can find me on Facebook Twitter
Instagram or subscribe to my animated
movie review series right here on
YouTube then you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights well catch you back
here next week with the worst of Michael
Keaton on a brand new episode of top 5
I'm gonna leave you with these two words
and those two words are I'm Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
you